makeup artist turned entrepreneur you
know her bobby brown she's making a
comeback after stepping away from her
namesake bran brand is it a comeback
we'll ask her she revolutionized the
beauty industry with her no makeup
makeup look in 1991 she launched her
namesake brand of cosmetics i remember
it well brown sold it to estee lauder
estee lauder back in 1995 she signed a
25-year non-compete agreement what she
left her brand back in 2016 but now
she's back in the beauty industry with
her new brand it's called jones road
beauty her goal is to create clean
beauty products that work on every skin
type and tone she's done that very very
well for years bobby brown is with us
first on cbs mornings it's so good to
see you good to see you i know i ran
into the lobby bobby i'm so glad to see
you
so i was fascinated by a 25-year
non-compete bobby i didn't even know
that was possible why did you agree to
that well i didn't know any better i was
in my early 30s and when i did the math
on my fingers i said i'm not going to
want to work when i'm in my 60s guess
what i launched this brand at 62 years
old
i know i bet you did you ever think
you'd be launching a brand in 62. no i
never thought i was going to do beauty
again i mean i you know i after we sold
the company i worked for 22 years as an
employee when i left i'm like i'm going
to do something different because i
always have seen you still working and
you called it jones road beauty so i
thought do you live on jones road no i
found it on waze what do you mean we
were driving to the hamptons my husband
doesn't like to be late and i checked to
make sure and i looked down and i saw
jones road and i needed to find a name
that was available that day or we would
have trouble with the launch
i love this yeah
speaking of your husband's been married
for 33 years 33-year non-compete class
called marriage yeah yeah
is that what they call it
the fine prince says uh what's it and
you co-founded the company with him
right yes yeah we've done a bunch of
projects together and i have a lot of
experience working with men i have three
boys
and so i kind of know how to get along
you know you just by the way ladies yes
how do you do that just say that's a
really good idea and then you do
whatever you want
yeah but you and steven do have a really
great partnership that it works and you
you told me once you said i don't
believe in failure what do you mean i
don't believe in failure because i think
sometimes the universe tells you to do
something different like i've done
things that haven't worked and you know
what so i do something different uh-huh
yeah so i love you you're wearing this
charm necklace with the significance of
that well i've been wearing this since
you know three sons i have their
initials i have a p sign for myself an s
for my husband and um i
have a charm when i left the old company
that is an ampersand and on the other
side i put the date the non-compete was
up which is the day i launched jones
road but bobby don't you think that it's
remarkable that they would say
you are so good at what you do exactly
that we don't want you competing with us
for 25 years and hopefully you'll be
retired and sipping margaritas on a
beach somewhere we won't have to worry
about you martinez martinis your drink
of choice so isn't that what is that
what's your reaction to that well you
know for me honestly i wish i had a
hobby i don't so i love working i love
creating things i love trying things
that i don't know what to do and i will
not you know this will not be my last
thing in the world you know i'm i feel i
i'm in the infancy of the rest of my
life what role does social media play
because when you launched all those
years ago we didn't have social media
right and now you become very
accomplished on social media
some people call you a tick tock star
bobby brown yes so what role does it
play well first of all to think you're a
tic toc sensation at 65 years old is
really scary but it has really worked it
reaches people great information it
literally quadrupled our business when i
went on tick tock wow so now it's back
to double so it's much better all right
all right but no enough of the business
talk while we're here
tips for people trying to look their
best this summer yeah well for me i you
know i'm known for the no makeup makeup
look because i think people actually
look great without makeup so the tip is
make sure i don't know about that
yes gail yes gail yes gail
and you know the tip the tip is just to
find things that work for your skin type
your skin color and whatever
humidity you're in or not but go lighter
you don't need heavy foundation
especially when you're outside
i'm always fascinated by your name bobby
brown yeah people walk up to you and say
sing my prerogative well yes they yes
they do my dad's name is james brown no
is it really really yeah
how many times does that cause you get
resurrected you must have interesting
bobby brown story i once stood outside
in chicago waiting for my limo to pick
me up to get to the oprah show a lot
when it was live
and no one was there and i kept calling
they're like the driver's there the
driver's there i'm like he's not there
finally it turned out he was looking for
him
they're not the godfather of soul yeah
no no no no bobby brown no bobby brown
we were looking for bobby brown yeah
yeah yeah that's so great well it's good
to have you back we know it's it's it's
a smash already congratulations
and 60 ain't so bad 60 something eight
so bad five not so bad honestly yeah
first grandchild on the way i can't wait
for that i can't either you're gonna
love every single minute
bobby brown congratulations
congratulations
to you thanks for having me